so my original plan was to have the take
two doctor who reviews start for doctor
who series 12 today um
that's gonna go on hold
because i've got something special
coming up
[Music]
first of all don't worry take two doctor
who reviews will come back i'm not
saying exactly when at this point
because i've got other stuff that i
really need to catch up on before i
start adding
back in the when regular wednesday
videos i'm just dropping this one here
as a preamble for the thing coming up
but also uh because i know some folks
were expecting a video today so here you
go
but
what i'm going to be doing is a new
project limited project at least for the
time being we'll see how it does
the mcu body count now what that means
is i am going to be going through
the major heroes of the mcu and trying
to figure out based off the movies
how many people did they kill
now this is admittedly more than a
little bit inspired by the kill count
done by the channel dead meat
and actually the initial impetus for
this was me see a clip of the primary
host of that channel james a genesis not
doing an infinity war kill count today
because i'm not doing an infinity war
kill count ever like ever ever you can
stop requesting it so my initial thought
was well if he won't do it maybe i
should
but that idea didn't actually energize
me that much partly because i just be
aping somebody else's
format and just doing a movie the way
that they would if they would have done
it and i abandoned that quickly but the
wheels started turning
i started thinking about
doing something count-esque but
approaching it differently if you don't
watch the kill counts over on deadmeat
which if you like horror movies you
should they're a lot of fun i'm not even
that big into horror i have a lot of fun
with those videos
but he goes through
on a per-movie basis going through every
death to figure out the total body count
of the film that's not what i'm going to
be doing i'm going to be taking the
heroes and going through all of their
film appearances in the mcu
and determining how many people they
personally
took out i'm not going to be doing any
kind of synopsis of the films we are
just going to be jumping through the
action scenes to figure out how many
people did they kill my initial plan for
this is to do six entries and this is
going to cover the original six avengers
so that is tony stark aka iron man steve
rogers aka captain america bruce banner
the hulk natasha romanov black widow
thor
and clint barton aka hawkeye now i'm not
just going to be going through the films
they did up to the avengers i'm actually
going to be looking at their entire mcu
presence
so
this is
not exactly a small project that i'm
looking at but i'm gonna start with
these six because that's about how many
that i figure i can safely commit to and
feel like i have a complete package of a
project now if it does well if people
respond well to these i might do more i
might look into heroes that were
introduced in phase two um i might look
into doing something maybe with dc
superheroes but let's not get ahead of
ourselves that's the goal right now
now that's the premise of what i'm doing
i want to talk a little bit about the
parameters and i want to do it here in
an introductory video so that i don't
have to bog too much time in the videos
proper explaining some of my methodology
here admittedly a lot of this is going
to come down to personal calls and i'll
do my best to justify in any given
instance as to why i think a certain
action taken by a hero did or did not
result in the person that they attacked
dying and it is going to be a judgment
call because honestly a lot of this
stuff is just they hit hard that's the
case with thor captain america hulk and
even some of the other ones who have
more traditional weapons like iron man
it's not always clear-cut and i am going
to make judgment calls on who i think
did or didn't survive so that's the
first thing i'm going to try and justify
my calls but it is going to be to a
certain degree subjective the more
important thing that i need you all to
realize is
i'm not counting literally everything
that was killed here's what i mean by
that i'm making the call to restrict
counting only kills against what appear
to be sapient or sentient beings and
what i'm not counting
are hordes or hive minds individual
parts of a hive mind at any rate so what
that means is things like the ultron
bots which don't really think for
themselves
would not count that would include the
four armed weird monster things that
bulk out thanos's army and that would
also
include the chatari which i know some
people are going to give me pushback on
that but i'll get into this into the
actual inaugural video proper but i have
evidence to support my claim that the
chitauri are in fact a hive mind and not
a collection of sentient
individuals but i'll get into that in
the video proper now there's a couple of
reasons why i'm doing this the first is
it
keeps my job from being impossible
because there are so many times that
these you know massive amounts of things
you know whether it be the ultron bots
whether it be the undead things raised
by hella like these things are so
numerous that actually trying to count
all of them becomes a impractical and b
saps the fun out of the project for me
that's the first reason there's also the
fact that part of what i'm hoping to
find out is which of these heroes is in
fact the deadliest who has the highest
body count and if i were counting each
individual member of a hive mind or a
mindless horde
well then it's tony it would have to be
he's the one who took out the entire
chitauri invasion by blowing up their
mothership he's the one who snapped
thanos and his entire army it would be
not even close
if somebody else has the patience to go
through and try and count every single
individual thing that he takes out
through those kinds of means have at it
i won't stop you
but i'm not gonna do it now that also
means that i'm gonna have to make a call
on creatures that don't appear
necessarily to be part of a horde but
don't necessarily appear to be fully
sentient there are certain kind of
monstery beast that you know thor runs
into whatnot and i'll make a call when i
get to them now the plan right now is to
do one of these a month for the next six
months
now there is the possibility if this
ends up being a little bit more work
than i think it's going to be which
that does happen to me sometimes i might
put a gap somewhere in there or maybe it
becomes every two months if i really
need it to be but i am committing
initially to these six
and we're going to start out
on saturday
this week
with iron man
so that is the premise
the parameters and the preamble
that just leaves me with one thing left
to do
welcome to the mcu body count
[Music]
now my thanks to my highest supporting
patrons robin moore zuma
the thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters andelke the
oath of boy bernabby lacks the poodle
zach idolin tracy skravitt angry casper
bookworm adam rdl taylor shane ross
gourlay brendon the rose and tt if you
want to hear me possibly butcher your
name check out the rewards on the
patreon
and thanks to all you friends
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]